hi my name is cliff and uh i'm here to
tell you how to do horrible things with
the jvm
so um
so hooning right a hoon mobile that this
is this is what it this is what hooning
means to travel at speed and the
confined area basically just be a jerk
um
and do horrible things with your car you
know like
more than just putting a wing on it you
know putting putting a turbo in
in a minivan
doing other terrible things it's kind of
what i like to do
to tell you a little bit about me
i'm cto of a company called boundary uh
we do uh monitoring so go to my one
product pitch go to free.boundary.com to
get 10 free servers under monitoring one
second level data it's cool stuff all
right product pitch over so
um we process a lot of data and uh i've
you know had to bend over backwards to
make a lot of this stuff work uh so
some of the things i've learned so
everyone everyone has uh
seen this quote before right premature
optimization is the root of all evil
news said it it must be right you know
um
so the thing about this and you know the
thing about this this quote is that i
think that this gets used as like kind
of a bludgeon a lot to um
to to justify bad and slow software uh
essentially so i i think people just
sort of trot this truck this thing out
to say oh you know it's good enough and
blah blah blah and then you know when
you're six months down the road and
you've painted yourself into a corner it
doesn't you know
anyway the the um the interesting thing
is is that how many people have actually
read the paper this came from
yeah okay cool
uh i would recommend everyone go and
read it you can find it online it's been
scanned into a pdf um and it's it's
actually it's a really interesting
argument because like if you if you look
at it contextually uh back in 1974 when
when they were talking about this uh
news was really talking about
go-to versus structured programming and
by structured programming i mean
you know if statements and uh uh
looping constructs right like like while
loops and for loops and you know um
recursion and all the things that we
actually take for granted as as working
and being fast right um but
in their in their time the big debate um
the big debate was uh between you know
using go-to's and and using um
uh between using go-to's to to tune the
code as tightly as possible uh versus
you know the trade-off you get with uh
with with you know using more structured
uh programming but by getting a much
slower program and in their day the
trade-off really was between the
readability of the code that you produce
um and the speed and there was a direct
trade there but but what newth was
saying was like hey look
uh you know
we should be writing
you
but his idea was that that the programs
that you write are going to have a life
cycle you know far beyond the the
tooling underneath of them right and so
the idea there is that you're going to
write something it's going to be running
somewhere for for quite some time and we
should be re writing our programs for
maintainability and then trust the the
tooling layer beneath to get better over
time so let's let's improve the
compilers let's improve the uh let's
improve the the you know the pieces
underneath so they can make this fast by
default as long as we have
well-structured programs which is
actually you know
when people use that quote they're not
talking about that at all
so and i think we're kind of at a
similar place now but in a different way
right because computers are very
different than they were
they're very different today than they
were back then um
and and
so i you know i would i would posit that
the limiting factor for most computation
is actually not the speed at which you
can
execute an individual instruction um
so you know the the the there's many
different there there's many other
bottlenecks that that are that are uh
much worse than than that for for
performance
um and and the other thing is that the v
is that vms and well we have vms now
they didn't even have them in 1974 but
like we you know the vms and compilers
we have they're they're a lot more
advanced um so it's a really a different
landscape and i just wish people would
stop using that quote um and i think
that you know what what we have today
with a little bit of massaging and
specifically the jvm in this talk
uh
you know it allows you to be able to to
write uh readable yet fast code
um so who who here's heard and i i think
yeah i think i think um
uh martin thompson's here too or maybe
not in the room but at the conference um
so uh very cool mechanical sympathy is
really uh
is a great uh turn of words the the idea
being that you write software that that
uh that is in sync with the machine um
and you know this is sort of my
techniques for doing it uh that i kind
of came up with
um through a lot of performance tuning
and yeah anyway memory latency so memory
latency is i think the big killer uh now
obviously these numbers are are kind of
nonsense and you know uh they're going
to be different depending upon what kind
of hardware you're on
but as you know sort of rules of thumb
or like general um
you know as far as as uh
as like sort of a general um
uh order of magnitude this this works
pretty well right and so
all the way at the top we have registers
and then all the way down at the bottom
well no one's using tape backup anymore
i think but um
you know the the uh
you know you have network access down
there and that can take
however long it's going to take and i
like to like i like to put this into
relative terms um to really give you a
sense of the numbers because you know
when you look at those numbers it's it's
it's hard to reason about them right so
i like to think in like in relative
terms
like let's say we let's say we were
equating one nanosecond to one mile um
and we're
we you know
the the analogy would be uh travel
distance right so registers that's like
about a mile about a miles walk um so
you know you could walk that
pretty pretty pretty easy to get to an
l1 cache is like a nice bike ride so you
know you're you're going um
you know it's a nice bike ride so uh you
know it'll take you about 20 minutes 30
minutes uh the l2 cache is like a
suburban commute you know you're going
40 miles out of the city center every
day coming back your life's kind of
hellish
uh main memory that's a day trip you
don't want to be doing this all the time
but uh every once in a while it's like
you know going from san francisco down
to santa cruz so it's it's gonna take
you the whole day
uh and then going to hard drive is
actually is literally going to mars um
so that's
yeah i mean it depends on the orbital
mechanics uh at the point in time you
know but
you're you're talking about you know uh
like 500 million miles or whatever it is
but um and then of course the network
who knows right it could be close it
could be far away it could never show up
it's just whatever you know interstellar
travel generation ship so goodbye and
we'll see you someday maybe and you'll
be a different species anyway
uh locality reference is um so so how do
we how do we deal with how do we deal
with the these caching primitives how do
we deal with this hierarchy of memory
because it's never going to go away
and the way that most these things are
built is to take advantage of locality
of reference
and um
the what this means is is that it's the
principle that if you're accessing
thing one you're probably going to want
to talk you're probably going to want to
access thing
the the thing right next to it as well
um
so you know the the the what the caches
will do is a lot of times they'll
pre-fetch things and they'll get things
in big blocks
excuse me getting over being
sick they're good things in big blocks
uh and and
you know if you're accessing things that
are close together uh it's more than
likely that they'll be in a higher that
they'll be in a uh
much lower latency cash so
that makes your code faster
and so the j the the back to the jvm uh
the jvm memory model makes this terrible
um
doesn't work right so
uh in the on the jvm you basically have
uh you have three regions of memory that
you you get to deal with
there's the stack and the stack gets
used uh for local primitives um
local object references so like
everything in the jvm is a pointer so uh
you know all the all the pointers you
have to the objects that are allocated
out in the heap you you can you can have
them on the stack
for the heap
um that's basically any kind of object
allocation so so anything that anything
that uh gets gets instantiated via the
new keyword goes onto the heap and then
you have the uh you know the the weird
direct stuff that you know crazy people
like me are always talking about which
is you know you get via direct bite
buffer which is kind of slow uh or the
uh or you can just use unsafe um as is
and we'll we'll get into that in a bit
um
and and so of these you know the heap is
where the gc primarily operates um the
stack is only for primitives so you
don't really get too much of a say in
what goes on the stack
and then the direct you have to manage
yourself
uh and so so what am i talking about
with primitives here so so the jvm has
this idea of the primitives versus
objects right and the primitives um
and and the primitives are mainly just
numbers right so you get uh you know all
the different widths of numbers you
don't get an unsigned type because you
know gosling doesn't love you and um
yeah uh so so yeah so it's just mainly
numbers and and for the the purpose of
of the talk we're just going to stick to
numbers but um
the problem with objects is that you
have a lot of you have a lot of overhead
with objects so you have a 12 byte
header on the 32-bit jvm
the header gets out to 16 bytes on the
64-bit jvm depending upon whether
compressed pointers are on um yeah and
so the compressed pointers will save
memory on your 64-bit jvm as long as
your heap is smaller than 32 gigs which
i hope it is because otherwise
well i mean if it isn't you should be
using the azul stuff anyways but anyway
um
and then the
the fields get reordered and packed
so part of the part of the memory model
spec for the jvm says that you you can't
really uh you're not supposed to know
where stuff ends up in memory so you
can't just
you know map a thing and and
uh you know
trust that it's going to end up in the
right place um the jvm does not let you
do that which is why most serialization
on the on the jvm sucks
and so java gives you this false trade
right so it gives you this uh
this this trade-off because of the the
the constraints of the memory model it
gives you this this this trade-off with
your programming where you know if you
want to have generic good you know what
we've all been told is good programming
practices right you have generic
algorithms uh you know you're going to
write your list structure once and it
should be you know
you should be able to use it for any
type right because because it shouldn't
care what type goes in it and that's
true but uh it comes with the overhead
of wrapping all the primitives up and um
you end up pointer chasing and it's
you know the overhead is just atrocious
so you're you're forced to choose um
you're forced to choose between flexible
and slow or brittle and fast um
and uh
it's actually a very different trade-off
than what newth was talking about um
you know the the because the inflexible
code is actually perfectly readable
you're just gonna have you know you're
just gonna have more of it right uh and
but but the the the problem isn't the
problem isn't that that it's not
readable the problem is is that
um it's it's too specific right and so
you have to uh to actually make changes
and to move fast you um you know you end
up having to do a lot more work
but the nice thing is is that there's
tools to fix this and so i've found a
lot of things uh i found a lot of things
that can that can help with this
and uh we're gonna go through them real
quick
so hppc um
i love hp pc so it's a uh so it's this
really cool collections library uh it's
on github it came out of uh i think it's
abandonware because i haven't seen it
commit in the repo for a while so kinda
but it's um it works really well uh so
hppc what it does is basically it it's a
whole set of collections and data
structures um that have analogs to um
that have analogs to the um
to the juc collections but it breaks api
compatibility which is great because the
api for the for the java util
collections uh has um you know it
automatically wraps things so hp pc has
all unwrapped accessors uh it'll it
it'll actually give you access to the
underlying you know array like the
actual literal primitive array if you
want um and it's really cool uh it uses
code uh so it's it's like a sort of like
a hacked together uh c plus template
right so the the way the library works
is that there's
it uses generics it looks like generics
in the code um
but it goes through a post compiling
step where it generates you know the
cross product of you know
you know like int to long and it
generates a cross product all the
primitives um so the jar ends up being
gigantic but uh you know you
most jars are gigantic by the time they
get into production so yeah
it's always a trade-off right uh but
yeah so hppc it's really cool um i've
used it to great effect you know
basically dropping it in and getting
automatic speed ups is awesome
and so here's another thing this is the
thing that that i wrote um
it's called fast tuple
so we're going to get into it in a in a
few minutes here so uh
so you know java so java's is a
statically typed language but the jvm is
extremely dynamic and it's this weird
sort of dichotomy where the there's all
this dynamic stuff under the hood that
is kind of hidden from you
unless you know the escape patches to
get to uh so because it has hot code
loading
so you can load
you can load new code at runtime
um and the cool thing is is that what
fast tuple does is
it has a code generator
it it compiles schemas into java code
via project called genino
and using that code generation
essentially what it does is you can
delay defining your static types until
runtime so essentially you know if if
you think about static typing as saying
you know having to pre-define your
schema or you know you're the layout of
things um you know at the at the time
that you write it
what's what this is doing is it allows
you to allows you to delay
it allows you to delay that
that declaration until you have
sufficient information to to be able to
do that so so if you think about an
analytic system where you know you might
want to accept a new data type instead
of having to make code changes just to
find a new schema and that can all be
done at runtime
and i'll show what that looks like in
just a moment
yeah and so what it does is it generates
contiguous contiguous
arrays of tuples and so you can store
many thousands of uh of heterogeneous
tuples inside the jvm
with without um
you know without using too much memory
and um i'll show you how it does that in
just a minute this is what it looks like
uh so can everyone read this okay uh so
so um you define your schema you give
the field names you can give them types
uh you can tell whether it's you can
tell it whether to to allocate on the
heap you can tell it to allocate direct
so into direct memory um
and then from the uh from the schema you
can you can generate a new tuple you can
generate an array of tuples and it even
has a even has an expression language
too so if you want to do operations on
these you the expression language will
get compiled down into java byte code
and
suddenly now that that byte code is is
now available for up available to
hotspot for optimization so
the the cool thing is is that
you know you can you can basically write
an entire analytics pipeline with this
uh have it all be generic and actually
accept you know random expressions from
uh you can have it accept random
expressions from your users to do
analytics
and they'll all get compiled down the
byte code and so you don't have to make
that trade-off of you know we're doing
more dynamic stuff but it's going to be
slow it doesn't have to be that way um
so i don't know i think it's cool
so here's the some results from the last
benchmarks i ran uh now obviously most
benchmarks are lies this is probably a
lie as well
so you know take it with a grain of salt
but it's pretty fast
so
essentially
for for accessing for accessing
individual for accessing individual
fields you're looking at a couple of
nanoseconds um
you know on heap is actually a lot
faster um
because when you look at the assembly
that gets generated it does there's it
does a little bit less stuff um
um the the the big the big weird one
here though is when
when you actually do the allocation on
through the direct uh on onto the um
yes so fun fact when you do direct
memory allocation um using unsafe uh
it's actually a jni call so
unsafe.allocate memory goes through jni
which is expensive and slow
anywho uh let's do a demo
so we're gonna look at hppc real quick
and uh yeah this is really really
hang on i'll all i'm big in this
yeah that's
not gonna work there we go
okay
so
okay perfect um so this one's the fast
tuple okay hp pc here we go so
can everyone can everyone see what's
going on in here
so essentially uh so we're using the hp
so we're using uh the hp pc hash map so
this is the um so this is an open hash
map that maps integers to longs um so
we're just so we're just you know
allocating it with uh the size n where
we're saying n is a million and then
this this loop right here we're just
putting we're just putting the numbers
in here uh essentially we we want to
make sure that we don't trigger a
reallocation so we're putting it below
the load factor
so that's just to explain what's going
on here so nothing up my sleeve um and
then memory measure is a library that
uses
the java agent api to actually measure
how many bytes allocations are taking uh
and so this is and then this is
basically the same code down here but
just using uh java's regular hash map so
um
yeah and and that's exactly what this
does so let's run it see what happens
and
it did stuff yep there you go
yeah and so we can see right here with
hppc um those you know that hash map of
a little less than a million things ends
up taking you know somewhere about 27
million bytes uh with but with the java
util hash map it's about 62 million
bytes so you can see like the the just
the overhead of doing primitive
operations and with the regular java
stuff is not great um
so we have this one here
so same same i uh
yeah so same same idea right so uh
uh so this is this is uh so this is just
gonna show you like you know the
difference between you know a primitive
array and a uh there between a primitive
array and and uh you know a wrapped
array so you know this is this is just a
stripped down version of the last one
but again you're gonna see
how much stuff gets wasted um
and
you know you're talk you're talking
about four million bytes versus uh wait
versus 20 million yeah 20 million bytes
so
it's
you know the the trade-off you're forced
to make is is just it's kind of stark
when you look at it and then here's fast
tuple which is really cool so
essentially um we're gonna
you know allocate an array of fast
tuples uh on heap just to make sure it's
a fair comparison um and uh
we'll also so that memory memory measure
can measure how much it takes and then
this is a list of a list right so if you
so if you for instance if you use um if
you storm uh all your tuples in storm
are actually like a like an array list
underneath the covers and so this you
know if you're pushing you know millions
of integers per second through storm
this is the kind of uh it's kind of
overhead you'd be looking at right so
let's run this guy
and it's going to take a while
there we go yeah so 4x difference
between you know the uh between the list
of lists versus a bunch of fast tuples
so
you know ta-da
the demos worked anyway uh so that's
memory um so the moral of that story is
use primitives and um
you'll be happy and everything will be
nice
actors threading
uh
that went the wrong way there we go
so um you know i wrote a blog post not
too long ago that insulted a lot of
people um
you know
mainly people who you know maintain
actor frameworks i i've never so i've
tried to use a lot of stuff i've even
written my own um that i don't recommend
you use uh most of my open source is
just me trolling myself in the future
yeah so i but i've never used an actor
framework that you know really
felt good uh you know because i'm coming
at it from the perspective of being a
long-time erlang programmer and i love
doing actors in erlang and it's never
it's never you know first of all the
experience you know the user experience
of actually
writing actor code on the jvm has never
felt right it's never it's never been
the magic of erlang honestly um because
you can it's so easy to do all this ooky
stuff and and and to screw it up pretty
badly um
and you know it's just not the right
platform for it i don't think
the the java really was written to meant
to to do one-to-one with native threads
um and i i i'm asserting right here is
my opinion but uh you know the the best
way to distribute work um
you know to do concurrent work is just a
thread pull executor consuming events
from a disruptor or a queue
sorry you can't have a pony um
you know because you don't have because
you don't have guarantees around shared
memory you don't have uh you know you
don't have a garbage collector per
process you don't have multitasking of
the green threads either
so
you know that's a thing
and and even the and so you might say oh
killum has a bytecode weaver lots of
things have bike code weavers the
problem with the bike code waivers is
that they screw up
they screw up hot spots ability to do
inlining um
because they blowed out the method sizes
in the bytecode
so anyway i think the i think the moral
of the story with threading is that um
you know obviously you could do a whole
talk on doing proper threading in java
but essentially like the the the seat of
stuff is kind of just the way things
work on on java right so you paralyze
work on the natural units of work um you
have events coming in through a queue or
a disruptor or whatever
and then essentially you just try to try
to spin up the cores to do as much work
as possible um that that's it and you
have to if you and you have to tune
things yourself um so everyone has that
one you know thread pull executor that
has a magic number of threads and no one
really knows why why it's the value it
is it's like 40 threads that seems it
works
you know um so obviously performance
tuning and benchmarking uh is huge right
like you have to do it because there is
no no one no one to my knowledge has has
implemented a thread pull executor that
can auto scale and if you're gonna and
fork joint pull is definitely not the
answer um
has everyone read the the javadocs to
phaser
the the locking
yeah
does anyone understand them
i don't think so
me neither um yeah micro benchmarks um
so micro benchmarking is is uh it's
really cool it's how i did the
benchmarks for fast tuple
and you know the benchmark code is up on
is up on github as well um but micro
benchmarks in java there's actually
there's finally a really good framework
for doing it and micro benchmarking is a
very powerful way of asserting uh that
that you know the the
the jit is doing what you think it's
doing um
because um because of the the warm-up
period right so
the uh
so you can you can optimize certain
patterns you can optimize little tiny
pieces of code to be able to to build a
better mental model of what the jvm's
doing under the surface so i think it's
a really powerful tool when used in
moderation
and jmh is the is the tool to do it jmh
is awesome uh so it's maintained by the
the job performance group so um there's
uh there's one guy uh alex shipley uh he
he does a lot of work on it he's he's
cool to follow on twitter because it's
like goes back and forth between like
english and russian and you know it's
cool um
the the uh so it's annotation based uh
it's it's it's neat what it does is it's
a uh it's a post processor so you write
out your code you're writing your
benchmarking code you put annotations in
uh and then it runs as part of your
maven as part of your maven build builds
out does a bunch of weird bike code
stuff and builds out this this this cool
little uh benchmark jar
and and you can it's a so it's an
executable jar it has a bunch of command
line options and then you can you can
tune it right so you can you can um you
can give it the number of threads to get
to to use you can give it the warm-up
periods um there's all sorts of of
interesting options that you can use to
to tune it and to to basically try to
try to get try to get out what you're
you know what what you're looking for
and the the reporting is all standard so
you can share your results with other
people and it's great uh i mean that's
that's what it looks like too like it's
really really simple see one of the one
of the one of the great things about the
about about jmh is that it provides
automatic black holing uh so a cool
thing so so the so the
back up a bit so the hotspot
so hotspot is is smart enough to
understand when you have dead code so
like when a result of when the result of
a computation isn't used anywhere it
will automatically
take that piece of code and say yeah you
know what you don't need to execute
because no one uses your result
so most benchmarks actually fall
technically fall under the category of
dead code because they're just doing
stuff for the for its own sake
so what jmh does is if you
inside of your benchmark method if you
return the result of your computation um
it will automatically it'll it'll it
does what it calls black black holing
the the result and i don't know what
actually happens there but supposedly it
it it makes it so that the said that
hotspot doesn't automatically
mark this as dead code uh it's really
cool
so it keeps your benchmarks at least
somewhat honest
and that takes us to to working with the
jit um so this is really um where you
can get into some
some interesting stuff
um so i what i like to do is i i like to
sort of structure and design my code for
for how the jit is going to or at least
the mental model i've built up of what
the jet's going to do
um so a lot of this is writing short
methods um so there's actually so
there's a jvm there's a tuning parameter
on the command line that you can set the
uh you can set the max so you can set
the the maximum size of method uh for
inlining because
what what happens is that if it's beyond
like 36 bytes i think something like
that so if the uh if the byte code is
beyond a certain size uh that method
will no longer be a candidate for
inlining
so it's 325
thank you thank you so he said it's 325
if it's a hot method so um
by default so um you can tune that uh
you can tune that in the command line
see if it makes a difference but what
you really should do is write shorter
methods um
you need to uh what else yeah because
actually the the funny thing is most of
the performance gains
excuse me most the performance gains you
get
from uh from the jit actually all come
from inlining
uh it's it's it's it's like the 80 rule
right so most of it comes from inlining
um
and you just kind of structure things to
uh to take advantage of the inlining so
um
like like polymorphic dispatch from the
same call site so what do i mean by that
so you know you have your your object
hierarchy right so you have two objects
uh you know two classes they um you know
they both inherit from the same thing
and they have a you know an abstract
virtual method right
so if they have that abstract virtual
method you know if you're in c plus plus
you'd you'd you'd always have to use the
the
the method table but in what what what
the jit does in java is it looks at that
and as long as the call site is
monomorphic in other words as long as
that call site always goes to one class
the jit will see that and it'll say oh
okay cool you're never going to go to
the other thing so i'm just going to
inline so so this is now candidate for
inlining so it can even inline like an
invoke virtual as long as the call
site's monomorphic
um but if you have a polymorphic call
site in other words if you have you know
let's say you're looping over uh let's
say you're looping over an array or
looping over a list and then you have
one you know one side of the hierarchy
in is is in the list the other side of
the hierarchy is also in the list
they're all mixed up and heterogeneous
you know they both inherit from the same
thing um that means that that that call
site is is now polymorphic and so that
that call site is not going to be able
is not going to ha it's not going to
have the same opportunity for
optimization um so what's going to
happen there is it'll always go through
the v it'll always go through the v
table and you you can't uh you can't get
around it um so yeah
don't do that
keep uh small objects local so uh so
java has this thing called escape
analysis so like it's kind of a lie when
they say that objects always go on the
heap they don't always go in the heap
sometimes
you know i need to catch this in the
wild one of these days but sometimes
supposedly it will it will um
it will allocate them on the stack
i mean you don't know it's on the stack
but supposedly sometimes it'll allocate
them on the stack as long as as long as
the escape analysis says that the uh
that the object does not escape from
that scope um i'm not sure whether
that's true or not but all the docs seem
to suggest it so
like i said you got to catch it in the
wild to make sure it actually exists
um and then yeah so there's uh and then
using intrinsic methods is really cool
so there's the so there's certain
methods in the standard library that are
actually it's sort of like uh they kind
of just punch out and go directly to
assembly um so
there's uh so they're stuffed in uh java
lang math so pretty much all the calls
in java lang math are actually
implemented natively uh system dot array
copy is is implemented natively and and
i don't mean when i say natively i don't
mean jay and i so you're not paying the
jni costs except with the allocate
memory for i don't know why um but for
most of these it's actually it's it's a
literal it's a literal replacement of
that code with with with an assembly
macro
so you don't have to pay the penalties
and it ends up being extremely fast it's
really cool
and you can you can you can find where
the where they are
so if you go to so if you search for the
open jdk uh the open jdk
source control uh
librarycall.cpp has has all the has a
big list of all the um
of all the intrinsics yeah
so if you really want to know what the
jet's doing and how you you know catch
these things in the wild and actually uh
find it um
is is uh by by doing the print and
lining and doing the print assembly um
and then using those with with j with
using those with jmh to make sure that
the method you're calling gets hot
right um and so this is uh this is what
an assembly dump looks like this is a an
assembly dump from uh
from fast tuple and uh from
from its
uh benchmarking suite so the cool thing
is that inside of the assembly dump you
you get um
you know it it'll it'll annotates things
with the with uh with the source code
right which is really which is really
nice so even if you don't know assembly
that well um you can still kind of
follow along and say oh okay you know i
know all these things are related to a
new i know all these things are related
to this method so you can sort of like
paul your way through it and and you
know maybe learn a little assembly along
the way to see what's happening um but
essentially you know if a lot if if an
instruction results in a lot of assembly
you're probably doing something wrong um
yeah
so
so these are the the
some of the stuff that i mentioned in
the talk uh the mechanical sympathy list
is really good for like if you have
questions because like all the people
who do this stuff all the time for a
living are on there and they're they're
actually really nice and they don't yell
at you for being an idiot um
there's uh jmh um the hotspot wiki has a
lot of that sort of folklorish stuff um
but it's it's really good like it you
know to as a starting point for finding
these weird optimizations like they got
a buddy of mine found uh
actually actually he he
was he found uh like vector
vectorization was happening in certain
cases with with java seven and it's like
you know he went on a hunt to try and
find it and yeah anyway the the jet does
all sorts of weird stuff so it's it's
cool um
yeah hppc that's uh
uh you know the perform the high
performance collections and fast tuple
etc so anyways questions
yes
um
three calls tends to be three cases
tends to be problematic and obviously
but like two two calls is okay oh okay
yeah okay cool so so what he said was is
that it with the polymorphic dispatch it
turns out dimorphic so two so if you're
calling out the two things it's it's
gonna it
it can actually inline um
if you're calling out the three though
then you're hosed so awesome
how did you measure how many bytes of
data structure
oh uh so that was uh so that's a library
called uh um let me let me bring it up
for you because that's a that's a great
um
that's a great uh uh question um where
is it ah crap oh it's not in here okay
um so that is a uh
hang on
no no no no so that's uh so it's
something object explorer.memory measure
so what it is it's uh let me let me
bring up the uh
this is really hard to do on a
uh
wait where is my
uh
oh
run there we go
hang on
this is like really hard to do looking
at this skew uh run configuration
bring up the no i want the [ __ ] run
configuration oh here we go edit
configurations
yeah yeah uh so yeah so it uses a java
agent
uh so it uses this this agent path and
the agent api uh and allows you to uh
it's called it's called object explorer
so you just load this jar as a so you
load that jar using the java agent um
command line and it
it gives you the api that you can use to
actually measure the allocations um and
it walks the object tree and it's
actually true byte measurement so it's
not like estimating anything
and it can do that because it has
because it's using the agent api so it's
really cool um
yeah
object explorer sorry i didn't put that
in the resources but that's that's a
good
fast question does that have anything
for strings or variable length objects
so the question is does fasttuple have
anything for strings or variable length
objects no
uh i mean i can imagine
it's not a use case i have
if somebody asked for it we could figure
out how to do it um but it's you know i
i avoided it on purpose
i wanted to make it easier for myself
the knowledge you're um
oh that's a good oh yeah yeah that's a
good question yeah i totally glossed
over the string yeah so the question was
he didn't see anything about string
encoding and that's a great question
that that
yes string encoding screws you pretty
badly um so there's uh
yeah so there's like big locks inside so
if you're so if you're doing string
encoding and you're looking it up using
like the the actual utf-8
so if you say utf-8 in a string
when you're doing like the git bytes or
whatever it what'll happen is it will um
it goes out to this like hash map off in
the distance and uh there's a lock
around it so if you're doing this so if
you're doing this like like let's say
you're you're writing a you know a high
concurrency server that pulls in a lot
of strings from the internet uh what's
going to happen is every time you do
that in coding if you if you call if you
call out wrong every time you do the
encoding it's going to uh it's going to
hit contention on that that weird hidden
uh hash map there yeah encoding ends up
being awful so when uh the so the actor
library that i uh so the actor library
that i um
um i'm not gonna try to navigate up here
but so the actor the actor library uh
that i wrote called scaling um it's it's
terrible except for the strain encoder
so the string encoder uses uh uses
unsafe to actually map the bite straight
straight on so it's just going to assume
that you're uh you know that you're just
just
you're not doing anything fancy right
but it's essentially it maps the bytes
directly onto uh directly onto the byte
array of the uh of the string object and
it doesn't go through any of the
encoding [ __ ] so it's like super
fast it's good
right
yeah yeah it's it's it's
yeah i mean it's super it's super janky
right like if you're trying to do if
you're trying to do things like other
languages are actually doing coding it's
a bad idea right but if i'm if i'm
if i just want ascii stuff off of the
off of the uh off the wire and i know
it's going to be that like i can
why why go through the pain
so but yes you're correct it's janky as
hell
yep
yeah yeah exactly it just yeah it just
doesn't do any of the checking that
normally happens in the encoding process
so
yeah kyle story uh
right yeah so so kyle's saying using
using string utf-8 is is is fast is
sometimes faster than
than going i'm sorry i just totally
butchered that up uh
yeah anyway
yeah it is it's pretty pretty horrifying
well i mean well if you're scala fan you
know uh symbols and scala have a similar
like interning nightmare inside of them
uh so if you're trying to intern new
symbols so like like let's let's say
because you wanted to get fancy you know
you're pulling things off the wire
you're dynamically interning symbols um
that goes to a big map hidden behind the
standard library that has a lock around
it
yeah
correct correct don't do that um
but i've been dumb enough to do that in
the past so that's why i know
damn
wow
hecklers all right yep all right i gotta
wrap it up but uh thanks everybody